suppose you have why some function of X
we're gonna tell you what it doesn't
matter what and at some point you notice
certain characteristics about the first
move and about the second derivative
okay so for instance suppose you knew
that the first to review was negative
okay so for the news what would that
tell you about the graph my better
that's an algebraic statement
geometrically what does it tell you it's
the first derivative it's just wondering
how confident people are it's decreasing
isn't it it's going down something like
that whatever okay that's okay what
about if the first derivative is zero
and there's a few different kind of
staging points on there
right so you could draw it as a horse on
the board inflection it or it could be a
max it could be min whatever okay that's
fun
naturally if the first attribute is
positive if you get an increasing
function no problem no that's because
the first year we chose about the
gradient because the gradient function
the secondary doesn't tell you about the
great it tells you about having okay so
let's see how we are we Patrick if I get
the secondary
we pave concave down right service or
something like that or something like
that really for this it would actually
be something like that they're all
concave down if you poured water on that
they wouldn't stay all right let's keep
this receptor what is the second
derivative for positive now if the
second derivative is equals zero
pause for a second I want you to recite
in your head what that tells you about
the ground just say it in your head in
the quiet of your mind now that you have
it there I want you to say all out loud
at the same time kind of three okay are
you ready
commit one two three all right what
happened what happened now actually in
some ways your overall okay because let
me do they just follow this thing okay
decreasing increasing is this one
decreasing or increasing it's it's
stationary which is another way of
saying it's not increasing or decreasing
that's a stationary means so therefore
you are concave down to concave up this
means it's it's not concave anything
now that's what it really means I didn't
ask anything about points I just asked
him out what kind of behavior is
exhibiting know what does the concavity
mean what does that look like now you
already because a lot of you said points
and pressure you have in your head don't
you okay but let's do science because
you get lenses right that's what you
just need the idea of concavity so what
does a concave lens look like sort of
like it's sort of like an hourglass
shape isn't it that's that's a concave
lens what's the opposite of convex okay
so I suppose using our language we would
say that's like concave now what would
it look like if you had a lens actually
wouldn't be much of a lens anyway but
had no concavity look like it would just
okay which is why if you take say oh I
don't know something really complicated
like it was that look like we take the
first derivative and you get one see you
take the second derivative the do
different one is zero it's it's it's the
straight things I did points of
inflection no of course not because it's
not what is a point of inflection what
it's when you go from one of these to
the other you have to change state and
that's why some of you were there are
you said possible okay but it's kind of
like for a question like this like why
am I even thinking about whether it's
possible or not
so therefore what I'm trying to dry is a
lot of you are in in your working there
was a question that talked about there's
a graph I can't no wonder you crazy wars
okay but what have you done this you
said this
okay it's not soda right please do not
skip the fact that if you want one of
these okay what you must establish is
changing it from this to that or vice
versa
okay that's why when you go in for these
is no way to get around the table of
values okay one and you've got to test
to the left and to the right okay let's
get a question do we actually need to
put some numbers in here okay yes you do
but why why okay because you can always
just say you know most questions you'll
know in advance whether there is going
to be a inflation or not it'll be like
five the points of inflection okay I
guess there are points of inflection
right or for max me it'll be on find
where it is
so you already know that information so
you can't just say yeah